I'm in a genuine Scottish man oh man
Paul gillies most me this boy is about
the rough look at me and three scottish
things to wrap around okay we got the
kilt Thank really young balls in this
video then we got bak first okay all
right you know yeah yeah yeah go ahead
me edinburgh edinburgh by classical
kills okay cool ain't got no beat but
y'all know it's on it time i talk about
bockfest that's a tonic wine made by
monks over there yeah easy they got the
high abv in the monastery I try and do
the challenge Nick it down so fast i
love it when I fill my belly with blocks
fast BF like best friends forever when I
have the book fast we all join together
all we're so good so drunk you cannot
fake it underneath the kill you know we
all naked no wonder we're down they're
just they're free it's like Willy and
while is ww meet all running down with
the face covered in world is so cool in
Edinburgh on the show Edinburgh Festival
best of all in August everybody like in
thrall Edinburgh also it's ever so
pretty more stuff in Aberdeen that's the
granite city I know that you're a put on
the show y'all for Paul Gill EPG from
Glasgow
hahahaha